Este es el frente de krinna es batove
que lleva activo desde hace semanas con
contrafensivas tanto de las fuerzas
rusas como ucranianas esta posición
donde nos encontramos hay un cañón trf 1
dado por el gobierno francés que apoya a
la Infantería ucraniana en la defensa de
estas posiciones
este cañón dispara con mucha precisión
es muy útil porque la cantidad de poder
humano con la que ataca Rusia es muy
diferente mucho mayor a la ucraniana
ellos pelean con cantidad sin
importarles las pérdidas humanas que
tengan como porciones
vemos fotos y videos de ellos en directo
mientras atacan nuestros drones de
reconocimiento lo ven les disparamos
ellos pierden una oleada de Infantería e
inmediatamente envían otra atacarnos y
así una detrás de otra y otra
los soldados que están ubicados en estas
posiciones esperan la llegada de la
primavera en un momento en el que el
clima no solamente se hará mejor sino
que esperan la llegada armas como estos
ellas dicen que es extremadamente
necesaria para poder lograr la victoria
que están buscando
cuando trabajamos intensamente los
recursos que Francia usaría en años
Nosotros los usamos en pocos meses
[Música]
es imposible negociar con este enemigo
sin nuestra victoria usted ha visto lo
que ha pasado con las poblaciones que
han sido capturadas la única posibilidad
que tenemos es ganar
por eso necesitamos mucha munición
estamos muy agradecidos pero realmente
La necesitamos